gulliver craag à caligny fca donc au
coeur au centre du pays qu'elle est là
quels sont vos informations sur la
situation dans le reste du pays
alors je pense que vous avez
probablement diffusé ces images
terrifiantes de sept missiles qui a
frappé un immeuble d'appartements à kiev
c'est ça fait partie de cette attaque
sur kiev qui selon les dernières
informations est toujours en cours à
différents endroits les ukrainiens dit
savoir repousser des tentatives des rues
ste pénétré dans la ville et sur les
réseaux sociaux les ukrainiens se
félicite félicitent leurs forces armées
de cela mais je pense que la tâche n'est
pas terminée et il est rien n'est moins
sûr que ce que les ukrainiens puisse
réussir à défendre kiev si cette attaque
continue il ya clairement une
détermination de la part des russes de
prendre la capitale tout comme d'autres
villes comme archives sur laquelle il y
à des tirs d'artillerie encore assez
intense je pense aujourd'hui et puis
aussi à l'extrême ouest du pays à brody
non loin de lviv c'est le maire de lviv
qui l'a confirmé il y a eu des
parachutistes russes une soixantaine qui
ont été repoussés par les forces armées
ukrainiennes de brody mais ok mais qui
ont puis refuse pris refuge pardon dans
une forêt voisine lui c'est une ville
vers laquelle beaucoup de gens se
repérer en pensant que au moins loi là à
l'extrême ouest du pays les gens
seraient à l'abri il y a beaucoup de
déplacés qui se sont rendus à lviv et
bien le maire de la ville vient de
confirmer cette attaque à brody qui est
dans cette région là vraiment très très
très loin à l'ouest de kiev merci
beaucoup de l'hiver craque pour toutes
vos informations